uh there is a video clip I'm going to
play for you here
of Maria Bartiromo a Fox News host who
has gone from pretty damn good Financial
reporter 20 years ago to conspiracy
theorist Trump brown-noser suggesting on
her Sunday show yesterday that Joe Biden
is being fed drugs in order to function
and that Barack Obama and Jill Biden may
have known it and helped to cover it up
and asking who is really running this
white house it's quite a theory I must
say and during the clip I'm going to
play for you if you're watching you'll
actually see them put up a four box
graphic of the people they suspect might
really be running the White House might
really be in charge we're supposed to
believe that this is a news channel
this is supposedly a news program on Fox
not an opinion show all right let's take
a look at it there was
actually let me just even add before
before we do this Maria Bartiromo is
interviewing Ronnie Jackson Ronnie
Jackson is Trump's former doctor who
claimed Trump is 6'3 and weighs 239
pounds uh that's who's being interviewed
for context count councilman there were
signs
mining during the 20
he stayed in the basement the whole time
during during the campaign
um so who knew what when are they hiding
this and and feeding him drugs to to
allow him to function I know he goes
home to Delaware a lot more than any
other president so shocking that he's in
Delaware more than other presidents huh
I guess my question is what did Obama
know what did Jill Biden know and who's
running the white house right now and
are they covering up for these uh mental
uh there could be a cover-up here issue
well that's the big question everybody's
asking who's really pulling the strings
everybody's asking this guys I mean
listen Ronnie Jackson's telling you the
country right now we don't really know
the answer to that we don't know if it's
Susan Ross or Ron Klein or if it's Joe
Biden or who it is but somebody else is
doing this they're doing exactly what
you said they're rolling him at a
specific time and by the way they have
this graphic immediately ready
so it's very hard to believe that they
had a graphic ready with the exact
people that Ronnie Jackson mentions
putting up this four box is it really
Susan Rice running the White House is it
Ron Clane Brian D sir Jill Biden during
the day he's got good days and bad days
good uh you know and and whether or not
they have him on drugs I don't know
there are drugs out there that can
increase your alertness and your memory
and things of that nature you know it
covers stuff like this up temporarily so
I'm sure some of that's going on as well
but we don't know because his physician
hasn't stood up and took the questions
that I took when I was Trump's position
and answered those questions now it's
interesting how Ronnie Jackson says we
don't know but it does seem that that's
what's going on I mean he has no
knowledge of it it's not actually known
but he believes that it is going on he
says it must it is what's going on we're
supposed to believe this is a news
channel now aside from the level of
irresponsibility in this
I want to mention one other aspect of
this entire Joe Biden thing now you all
if you've been watching this you meet my
show you know I've said the 2022 and
2020 Joe Biden are not 2012 Joe Biden
Joe Biden humiliated Paul Ryan in the
2012 debates ran circles around him uh
had a rapidity and facility with the
facts and arguments that is is not where
Joe Biden is right now Joe Biden's
nearly 80 years old and that would be uh
common common if not uh typical of
someone his age but there's a couple
different things going on first the
level of total irresponsibility on what
are supposedly news programs now there
has been speculation about Joe Biden
which I engage in as well uh on opinion
programs and there has been speculation
about Trump as well but Fox claims to be
news and think back to when Trump got
out of his uh plane and and his car was
right in front of him and he just
wandered off and had to be brought back
by Secret Service when he was sitting
across from Rudy Giuliani and said
where's Rudy and looked around when he
said he wants to get to the oranges of
the investigation when he referred to
his himself as prompt instead of trump
when he referred to Barack Obama as
Obama when he talked about the drop
boxes and what I could give you the box
was silent Fox was silent so there's
also that hypocrisy and then lastly when
they talk about Biden was in his
basement
if Biden was in his basement
and suffering from cognitive decline
doesn't it make it even more humiliating
that a guy suffering from cognitive
decline who didn't leave his basement
got eight million more votes than the
sitting president now their counter
would be well those numbers were fake so
now you've got two conspiracies you've
got the cover-up of the cognitive
decline and the theft of the election at
some point we have to say guys that's it
that's it it's it's too far but they
don't even seem to get get how
humiliating it is for Trump to have lost
if those indeed are the situations
everyone is asking this Ronnie Jackson
says wait they are that's news Fox News
which they claim to be many of us know
what it's like to have acne show up when
we least want it to you should have seen
me in middle school now I'm on camera
and I really do the best I can to keep
my skin clear and for that I go to
apostrophe our sponsor on the apostrophe
website you just answer a few questions
take a couple pictures of your skin and
then you have a virtual visit with a
board-certified dermatologist who will
create a personalized treatment plan
they quickly ship you the prescription
medication I can tell you that when it
comes to acne
you're better off with a dermatologist
there are all sorts of different kinds
of acne that need different types of
treatment the over-the-counter stuff was
not what worked for me apostrophe makes
it simple and quick I've had a great
experience with apostrophe myself you
get affordable quality medical treatment
from a licensed dermatologist and
prescription meds that actually work but
I can do it all on my phone I don't have
to spend hours in a doctor's office my
audience gets 15 off your first
Dermatology visit go to apostrophe.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is in the description